[Music]
on this sunday night a dire warning from
ukraine
i'm ready for negotiations president
zielinski saying without negotiations be
prepared for a third world war
it comes with increased russian attacks
on civilians and a rising death toll
the pressure to end the war president
putin and his generals are testing the
resolve of the nato alliance why
agreement on a strategy remains elusive
grinding to a halt thousands of cp rail
workers are now on strike stalling grain
and the supply chain
[Music]
and the ukrainian victims of this war
reliving the horrors of the past
[Music]
global national
reporting tonight
colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us
ukrainian president vladimir zelinsky
says he's pushing for peace talks with
russian president vladimir putin but if
negotiations fail the results would
likely be a third world war
i'm ready for negotiations with him
i was ready over the last two years
and i think that
i think that without negotiations we
cannot end this war
in that exclusive interview with cnn
president zielenski also said russian
forces have come to exterminate the
ukrainian people
it does appear russia is trying to wear
down the will of the ukrainian people
with its indiscriminate shelling of
hospitals apartments and makeshift
shelters where civilians are hiding as
the war rages around them
that's the moment one of europe's
biggest metal plants in mariupol was
destroyed by a russian attack
and now russia says ukraine has until 5
a.m tomorrow moscow time to lay down
arms in mariupol russian officials claim
all who stop fighting are guaranteed a
safe passage out of the already
decimated city the scale of death and
destruction in mariupol is hard to
fathom this new satellite image shows
what's left around that theater turned
bomb shelter the words children still
clearly visible from the sky and now
reports an art school sheltering
hundreds of civilians in the same
besieged city was targeted our jeff
semple is in ukraine with more
as russia's invasion of ukraine stalls
its attacks grow increasingly
indiscriminate
the latest civilian target an art school
in mariupol where officials say 400
people were taking shelter that strike
follows allegations that russian forces
attacked a nursing home a theater even a
maternity hospital russia has committed
nearly all possible war crimes the
united nations said sunday that more
than 900 ukrainian civilians have been
killed including 75 children
i just want to cry i just want to shout
to other countries to please help us
said tatiana picatilleva
she runs this children's hospital in
odessa about a hundred kilometers from
the front line some of their patients
just arrived from the war zone including
a newborn
pakitillava says they've been spending a
lot of time down here
beneath the hospital a series of bunkers
previously used for storage now
converted into fortified hospital rooms
when they hear the air raid sirens up to
four times each day staff bring the
patients down here in case the hospital
is hit
we play films for the children so they
can't hear the bombs she says but this
is not a fortress we wouldn't withstand
a direct hit christina mitry zimlitz
zimlitt's 12-year-old son mark suffers
from a rare lung disorder the spider-man
superfan relies on a machine to help him
breathe
asked if he's afraid of the war
he says no i laugh at fear many of their
friends and family have already left the
country
we're desperate to leave but my son
requires special treatment equipment and
transportation she says we're trapped
here until we can find a safe way out
even the journey down into the bunker
can be difficult for him for others it's
impossible
this unit cares for sick newborns many
born prematurely this baby just had
stomach surgery
these babies cannot be moved into the
bomb shelter because they rely on this
life-saving equipment their doctor says
they would not survive she and her nine
colleagues were given the choice when
the air sirens sound go down into the
shelter or stay here exposed all of them
chose to stay
how can someone destroy a hospital like
the one in mariupol she says there are
no words
in mariopol where that hospital and
school were destroyed local officials
say the russian military is now adopting
a new tactic forcibly relocating
thousands of ukrainian women and
children from ukraine to russia
colleen
jeff semple in odessa in southern
ukraine jeff thank you
the u.n says 10 million people have been
displaced since russia's invasion began
february 24th most are fleeing to poland
but finding a way out is extremely
dangerous
[Music]
ukraine's deputy prime minister says
seven humanitarian corridors opened
today allowing more civilians to flee
the bombardment
of course pressure on nato to do more is
growing especially on u.s president joe
biden a group of u.s senators has
traveled to poland demanding biden green
light the transfer of polish fighter
jets to ukraine but as jennifer johnson
reports there are still no plans to take
that step due to fears of escalating the
conflict
as russia's military forces ahead trying
to destroy ukraine city by city calls
are growing louder for the u.s and nato
to do anything to make it stop before
it's too late that includes getting
poland's mig fighter jets into ukraine a
deal president joe biden will only
support if the u.s isn't involved
president putin and his generals are
testing the resolve of the nato alliance
so we need to see all of our member
nations come together show strength a
group of u.s senators is in poland
meeting with military leaders trying to
find solutions to stop russian president
vladimir putin other world leaders are
echoing their concerns warning if putin
succeeds this war won't be his last the
end of freedom in ukraine will mean the
extinction of any hope of freedom in
georgia and then boulder but it will
mean the beginning of a new age of
intimidation across the whole of eastern
europe president biden heads to brussels
this week for a nato summit on new
defense and economic strategies to
pressure putin the u.s has sent two
billion dollars in military assistance
to ukraine since biden took office a
billion alone last week after president
vladimir zelinsky made an impassioned
plea to congress a top ranking democrat
hints more firepower is coming there are
other ways for us to provide
surface-to-air missiles and air defenses
that will keep
the russians at bay and would not
jeopardize expanding this into world war
three or even worse
top u.s military leaders see russia
targeting more civilians and claiming it
has used hypersonic missiles at least
twice in ukraine as indications putin's
military is struggling the reason that
he's resorting to
using these types of weapons is because
he's trying to re-establish some
momentum is he running low on precision
precision guided munitions
does he have like complete confidence in
his ability to
the ability of his troops but putin's
ability to control the airspace over
ukraine remains a top concern even as
nato and many world leaders reject
repeated pleas for a no-fly zone over
the country
jennifer johnson global news washington
pope francis is once again condemning
russia's invasion of ukraine
he called the war a senseless massacre
with no justification and asked leaders
to stop the conflict he made his remarks
during his weekly sunday address in
saint peter's square many there wore
blue and yellow the colors of ukraine
thousands of cp rail workers across the
country are off the job a labor dispute
grinding a major part of the supply
chain to a halt farmers and dozens of
other industries are warning the impacts
of a protracted work stoppage could be
catastrophic dan spector has more these
canadian pacific rail workers in calgary
montreal and port coquitlam bc are just
a fraction of the 3 000 on the picket
line across the country after the
teamsters union and cp failed to reach
an agreement the company unfortunately
wasn't really in the in the mood to
negotiate with us so
here we are
the two sides have been in contract
talks since september each is blaming
the other for the dispute and for
causing the work stoppage but as
negotiations continue in calgary with
the assistance of federal mediation and
conciliation services people like
saskatchewan wheat farmer daryl franciux
are holding their breath the global food
supply is
is in jeopardy and this just doesn't
help cp ships roughly half of all
western canadian grain 75 percent of
fertilizer in canada is moved by rail
farmers here are now in limbo put the
blame on the unions and normally i don't
do that but i just see it as green on
their part unfortunately 45 canadian
business groups signed a letter last
week calling for binding arbitration
saying a stoppage could do irrevocable
damage to canadian supply chains in the
context of covet exploding commodity
prices and soaring inflation the union
blames the company for creating even
more insecurity while cp says the
teamsters acted irresponsibly by going
on strike before responding to their
last offer it's work conditions
more stable work schedule
obviously like everybody else there is
the
salary aspect of things the house of
commons resumes monday after a two-week
break and many industry leaders are
hoping the first order of business is
back to work legislation these kinds of
things like the blockades that happened
at the various border crossings these
really undermine our reputation as that
sort of reliable
trading partner labor minister seamus
o'regan is in calgary keeping a close
eye on discussions you know everybody
would agree can't go on very long
you know like i said there's just no
appetite in the country for this right
now o'regan is not committing to back to
work legislation saying the pressure is
on the parties involved every hour that
goes by is an hour too long for
manufacturers and for farmers in this
country dan specter global news ottawa
provinces across the country are slowly
emerging from the pandemic tomorrow
ontario and nova scotia scrapped most of
their indoor mask requirements but as
ross lord reports canada's top health
officials warn the pandemic is far from
over
after two years of facial coverings that
have annoyed some canadians and
infuriated others each passing week
brings more flexibility it's personal
freedom
on both sides definitely ready to take
off that mask if i go to a large group
like a hockey game or something i'll
probably still going to wear a mask etc
but
there's sometimes that it's nice not to
wear a mask like in a nice sunny day
like today coinciding with the arrival
of spring nova scotians are about to
breathe a sigh of relief no more
required distancing no more gathering or
capacity limits and at the same time as
ontario no more automatic masking except
for high risk settings and classrooms
most staff will probably keep their
masks on for the first little bit to
assess the situation
i'll definitely keep wearing my mask
proof of vaccine requirements are also
being removed other than in health care
settings with fewer canadians in
hospital the majority of other provinces
have already eased covet 19 restrictions
setting higher vaccine rates and a need
to guard mental health and the economy
but public health messaging on masks can
seem contradictory with the omicron ba2
variant causing infectious to rise again
in some parts of the world canada's top
doctor suggests it's too soon to resign
masks to the garbage heap of history
we're in a period of uncertainty
where
you know the the virus is still
undergoing evolution
so getting up to date with vaccines plus
wearing a mask is still a really good
idea as more restrictions are lifted dr
tams says a spring bump in cases should
not be surprising the hope is ba2
outbreaks will be offset by people
enjoying warmer weather outside where
the virus spreads more slowly hope also
springs eternal the canadians will
respect each other's decisions when it
comes to issues like if and when to mask
up
ross lord clover news
coming up a fight for survival the rival
gunning for the alberta premier's job
it's been a tough couple of years for
alberta's premiere and now jason kenney
is in a battle for his job party members
are set to vote at a leadership review
next month and an old foe has returned
with a clear mission to dethrone kenny
global's jamie dahl has more welcome
brian gene
a round of applause for alberta premier
jason kenney's biggest rival brian gene
is back in the legislature after winning
a by-election for the united
conservative party kenny was not in
attendance on this day jane is making no
qualms about it he wants kenny's job
jason
i hope you see what's coming and i hope
you
do the right thing the ucp cannot win
in one year unless you're gone kenny's
approval rating has been grim according
to the most recent angus reid institute
numbers at 30 percent he's the second
least popular premier in the country
many albertans are upset over his
handling of the pandemic
next month the ucp will hold a vote of
confidence on kenny's leadership and the
party's newest returning mla is now full
steam ahead making sure people come out
to vote he says the response so far has
been overwhelming events like this do
not usually
get more than
a few thousand people but to get
we expect more than ten thousand so
and in a population like alberta it's
great it's all about renewing the ucp
it's all about looking to have an
opportunity to
be competitive in the election against
the ndp in just a year from now jean was
a federal conservative mp and the former
leader of the wild rose party he lost
the leadership race to kenny in 2017.
as gene now mounts his offensive against
his rival kenny has also been gathering
his team together his chief of staff
recently took a leave of absence to
start campaigning i'm not confident i'm
hopeful people
are angry and when people are angry it
motivates them
i'm hoping cooler heads prevail this
political analyst says there's no doubt
albertus premier is in a fight for his
job when the leadership review was first
announced i was convinced that somehow
by hook or by crook jason kelly would
pull this out but there's more and more
evidence coming out that he's in real
danger that fate now rests in the hands
of party members who will decide if they
want to keep their leader the vote is
set for april 9th in red deer jamie dahl
global news calgary
just ahead the federal conservative
candidate who could be a king maker
the race to become the next leader of
canada's conservative party is growing
ontario mp leslie lewis has thrown her
hat into the ring again she placed third
in the party's last leadership race
buoyed by social conservatives but as
our chief political correspondent david
aiken reports lewis's goal now is to
broaden that support in a race that's
very different from the last one
she seemed to come out of nowhere in
2020 finishing a strong third behind
peter mckay and winner aaron o'toole and
since then leslie lewis won a seat in
the 2021 general election and now she
wants another crack the top job i'm
concerned about our 1.3 trillion dollar
debt i'm concerned about the divisions
and the demonization
and just the
the polarization that i see taking place
amongst politicians in 2020 lewis's
support was heavily concentrated in
western canada to win this time she'll
have to expand that base to vote rich
ontario and quebec her chief challenge
in quebec will be just as it was in 2020
an inability to speak french and to
party activists like yon plant who is a
senior aide to a harper-era quebec
cabinet minister speaking both official
languages is a non-negotiable
requirement for any national leader how
can you win an election i mean it's
impossible
right it's just mathematics it does
it doesn't add up
so so there's there's two at least two
angles to it there's one of respect and
there's one that strategically just
doesn't make sense another challenge
perceived front-runner pierre pogliev is
also likely to be attractive to many of
the western-based and social
conservatives who backed lewis in 2020.
this polyeff supporter who also served
as a top aide to harper era ministers
believes a lewis candidacy is very
different this time around
you know now that she's a newly elected
mp uh with a public record both in her
writing and her speeches in the house of
commons and her votes her campaign is
going to need to find a way to create
that same buzz or enthusiasm
now notably while pauliev patrick brown
and jean-charade have already taken
turns attacking each other
no one has taken aim at lewis and that's
perhaps a quiet recognition that just
like in 2020 one of them may need to win
over lewis's followers to put them over
the top when the race concludes in
september david aiken global news ottawa
tragic parallels up next how history is
repeating for ukrainian who remembers
have a look at this brave little guy
this jack russell terrier is reportedly
helping anti-bomb crews sniff out and
clear explosives in ukraine according to
social media posts by the state
emergency service of ukraine the doc has
helped deactivate almost 90 devices
since the invasion began
for most ukrainians this war began eight
years ago with russia's annexation of
crimea how it has unfolded is
unimaginable for most but not all as
mike armstrong reports for some this is
the second time they've lived through
the horrors of heartless aggression
there is a disbelief in this voice
margarita morozova is living through
horrors that shouldn't be but are
familiar
in my worst nightmare i couldn't even
imagine that such a massacre would be
repeated she says it's horrible
the 87 year old morozova lives in the
city of harkief it's just 25 kilometers
from the russian border for weeks it's
faced an almost constant assault from
air and rocket strikes
morzova's family has put plastic up over
the windows in case they shatter
and they have a plan when the bombings
get too close they all huddle together
in the hallway although she admits she's
not sure it's actually any safer
she says it's what she did as a child
the first time she lived in a city under
siege
morizova was just seven years old when
german soldiers attacked leningrad
russia the city now called saint
petersburg she tried to escape before
the city was encircled but she and her
mother missed a ferry a ferry that was
hit and sunk as it left
leningrad was cut off for
872 days
between the shelling and the starvation
1.5 million people were killed
at the time rationing meant morozova
survived on just a few slices of bread
each day a bread made of flour and
sawdust she remembers the famine she
says
and her mother telling her the scariest
thing was looking into your child's
hungry eyes and not being able to feed
them
morizova has lived in ukraine for more
than 60 years she has a daughter in her
kiev and a son in russia
that's where that disbelief comes back
the two countries are too close for this
she says their cultures and languages
are similar and she doesn't understand
how it's possible
morozova hopes for a quick end to this
war buildings can be rebuilt she says
but people who die can't be brought back
and then there's what the war is
creating something she calls a disaster
a hatred
between neighbors
mike armstrong global news jeshof poland
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm colleen christie it's
been a long winter across canada but
today officially marks the first day of
spring so we leave you tonight with
these beautiful cherry blossoms that
have just bloomed in bc's greater
vancouver area thanks for watching
jackson proska will be at the anchor
desk tomorrow have a good night